[Music]
welcome to here biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc it's time for another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting finally our
guest one-half of the famed vlogbrothers
Hank green course John Green who we
talked to a few weeks ago author of
Fault in Our Stars was on a near biscuit
now we get Hank he spends all his time
in Montana that's where he lives so
that's right I haven't been I'm never
been to Montana
I heard it's got big sky and there's
moose up there I want to go but I
haven't made the trip up there so we
have to catch him when he comes out here
on the west coast now we were humble to
find out that Hank said that he was a
fan of your biscuits and we were like
all right we want you to be on ear
biscuits I mean we've always looked up
to Hank for what he's done in so many
ways that I think will become evident
when we sat down to craft this intro to
kind of clue you in on who he is if you
don't know or don't know everything we
were just overwhelmed with the amount of
achievements he's had it you don't
really understand it until you just see
it all listed out so just really quick
just to remind you what he's
accomplished and he's a humble guy he
wouldn't want us to sit here and go
through these accolades but you need to
know so you can just appreciate who he
is and who it is we're talking to he
started the Eco geek web site that was
his first online thing that became
really well known but then he went on to
start just a few YouTube channels you
know the vlogbrothers crash course
scishow scishow space lizzie bennet
diaries the art assignment brain scoop
how to adult his personal channel Hanks
channel it's called Hanks channel he
doesn't have one called personal channel
it's just it's called Hanks channel
there's probably more that he's done on
YouTube well he's also started VidCon
the largest online video convention in
the world he created foundation to
decrease worldsuck which then creates
the annual online charity event project
for awesome which has raised millions of
dollars for various charities he also
co-founded the record label a
merchandising company which we are a
part dftba
he's released five albums musical albums
including his latest incongruent with
his band Hank green and the perfect
strangers and he created solvable one of
the first crowd
funny sights for all my video project
this is one thing I didn't know he even
invented 2d glasses that sounds like a
joke
you cannot it's glass that's for people
who get wigged out when they're watching
3d movies like it makes their head go
crazy like his wife works you can watch
it in 2d he'd like that
well he's purely a Renaissance man and
it's definitely evident in our
conversation on this week's ear biscuits
y'all we talked to him about the awkward
circumstances surrounding the first time
he met his wife Catherine and a story
that she herself has never heard we talk
about nerdom sexuality and the
surprising way that Hank and John chose
to deal with the success of John's novel
and the movie so we finally get to
complete the one-two punch of talking to
the other vlog brother Hank green here
it is our biscuit I think we we we are
live what we're not live this is
streaming out to nobody yeah the
conversation is live I do it on Ustream
we are having it live right to each
other yeah we're all really here and we
are living humans currently though
someone may be listening to this after
one or all of us has died if this comes
out in the next week or so as it as it
should yeah that's a sad thought but if
someone's listening to it like yeah eons
later right that's that's a really good
thought yeah people could be listening
to this ear biscuit in the year like
4020 that's an interesting song if
you're listening in the year 4020 please
leave a comment please leave a mental
holographic comment yeah which is which
is laughably commonplace in that many
years from now there will be no
differentiation between a digital
experience in a physical experience I
mean it won't even be digitally be
quantum a quantum experience sorry you
can't reach out and literally slap our
face right now not right which you could
probably do in the future and just to
present the other side of this we're
dead but they could interact with our
cadaver our captured bodies not our
literal
I think they might be able to pick up on
the DNA signature just by the sound of
our voice 2,000 years from now think
about that for a second boys gonna
happen are you subconsciously trying to
prove to Hank that you're actually smart
of a little bit I don't think that you
could fingerprints mark I'm not
comfortable with the idea I've listened
to plenty of ear biscuits I know how
smart you are
oh well I'm not gonna say I'm sorry I
was gonna say I'm interested interested
interested interesting I'm interested
okay curious I'm interested in you how
is LA do you still smell of Missoula how
long have you been here
I did see on your Instagram the evidence
of two trips to in and out in the first
day in LA I did we went to in and out
the moment we landed I got a I got a a
cheeseburger the first time with grilled
onions and the second time I got a
cheeseburger animal style
oh and what she prefer I preferred the
animal style oh yeah yeah I'm all for
the animal style I pick her on the
mustard into the bun and it's it could
be a little much I mean when you live
here you can be really picky you know
what I am glad of that we don't have in
and out in Missoula because if we did I
would eat it all the time and instead
Achatz be a special thing yes one day is
pretty special never done I haven't been
back since since the first day now I was
if I have I have a weakness for it
myself if I go a week without it like a
bad week I try not to eat a lot of red
meat right like it's yeah it is bad in
that way where I'm like you know I
probably shouldn't be all have you
didn't the 23andme thing
oh the genome yeah yeah I don't have my
wife got wind that I don't want my
genome on record oh really yeah cuz you
know what they're gonna do to you know
give me targeted advertising I'm just
messing with you in a sailboat huh
I can tell by looking at your jeans well
I've got it too for me as a Father's Day
present no it is very cool and I'm gonna
parently gonna get colon cancer oh I'm
gonna get colon cancer too
yeah fives yeah so uh I've cut seriously
down on the red meat yeah I've tried to
cut down on me a lot in general yeah I
have all sort of colitis so I like very
almost definitely will get colon cancer
it's um really my life if I live long
enough you describe that and in a little
bit more detail we just high-fived over
colon cancer did you know that what
happened in the room did happen so I
mean well I mean what is pooping like
and how long have you known about this
problem I have had you see for I was
diagnosed about 10 years ago and it's
painful and urgent is the technical term
like cramping yeah so like if when I
have to go to the bathroom I have to go
to the bathroom kind of thing like run
to the restroom yeah like if I'm on an
airplane and it's like during the times
when you're not supposed to go to the
bathroom and your special badge for that
had my wife did this for me I did not do
it she had the plane stop what taxi oh
so that I could go to the bathroom you
can hold it can't the car there's no
there's no holding okay I mean how deep
do want to get into gross because I'm
like perfectly comfortable with this
I've dealt with a lot of poo problems in
my life for example it would be very
difficult and during certain points of
my life to fart without whooping okay
which is a really sucky like way to live
and then like I remember when I first
got over that I was like so excited
about arts how did how did you get over
it
medication medication yeah and just like
the the feeling of farting without
having to worry of show sharding yeah
and my wife who does not typically enjoy
my farts was like really into it with me
which I really appreciate very cool
Kathryn was like yeah that one sounded
real good and I'm like yeah it was all
air that one didn't sound wet at all it
was all methane and like you know
there's like I have come to appreciate
farts in a very new way it was their
fear of being in those situations where
oh I'm just gonna crap my pants
absolutely it's like business meetings
can be really weird when you're like in
the middle of a conversation and you're
like
have to go and sometimes you want to
sort of like lead with that and be like
hey just so you know I have a medical
condition where sometimes I have to run
screaming out of the room does that
that's still the case
sometimes yeah though it's fairly well
controlled like even now is there like a
part of you that's like well okay we're
sitting around this conversation no it
could be an analyst there's always a
chance yeah talking about it does that
induce it does it no like weird things
do like stress does a calm which is like
great and like oh yeah you know what I'm
stressed out about the possibility that
might poop myself that's making me feel
more likely to poop - right mm-hmm
so I'm lucky to have a great job and I
have great support in my family and so
is that how you dealt with it with just
positivity I'm a pretty positive guy in
general but I I would say that I dealt
with it with medication and also you
know just sort of accepting that life
has to be the way the life is like you
don't complain about the snow you don't
say like man snow if we could only get
rid of snow we wouldn't have as many car
accidents and it would be cheaper we
wouldn't have to have so many plows all
the time and we could drive and you
wouldn't have scrape your windshield off
if only we could stop this no how do we
do that but there's an obvious bright
side like snow have you found that with
this condition it doesn't really have a
bright side you can't square sled on it
I think maybe character building or
something popular video about it once so
there's got some views there's always
that there's only that with any anything
in a writer or youtubers life
you're always like well this is a good
story yeah add revenue if there were if
I had the choice 100% of the time I
would choose to not have cheese sort of
glad yeah the other scary part of it is
that like the longer it's active the
higher your chances of getting cancer
and you know you have to get
colonoscopies all the time and those are
no fun and then if you get cancer then
you have to coal and removed and having
a colon removed is really unpleasant a
colonoscopy is a video have you thought
about it is yeah maybe post in that will
they give you a copy I think they
probably would give me a copy okay that
Katie Couric did then Katie Couric did
do that yeah cuz she wanted to encourage
people to get colonoscopies because
colon cancer there's one of the
causes of death and it's very treatable
right how nerdy are you I mean cuz
you've built a community around the word
nerd nerdfighteria weird now and I and
I'm like I have a hard time with it when
I like I come to Los Angeles and and I
get to hang out with the cool kids like
you guys are pretty cool okay thank you
and I'm like like Tyler Oakley is very
cool in grace like grace is like
specifically like not only are you very
cool but you're also like clearly the
hot girl and so it's very strange for me
to like are like are you guys do you
really want to hang out with like it
doesn't seem right and I'm 34 and I'm
still thinking this so that's one
quantification that I'm still like I
don't think the cool kids should want to
hang out with me okay so I'm I'm had I
have a hard time accepting that they do
despite the fact that it is clear that
they do in an irrational sense I get
that being a nerd is not defined by
relative social strata it is a little
bit defined by exclusion like that's how
I felt it when I was in high school like
right I was a nerd because I was not
allowed to hang out with the people who
were of the higher social strata and you
feel like in that sense it's been
corrupted a little bit with the the
trendiness of nerdiness I don't mind
that there's a there's a little bit of
like you know like you didn't go through
what I did to get that label so why do
you why should you have it in like now
it's cooled and suddenly you want it to
but I get that but that's it's not a
good thought that's not something that I
want to feel you're a legit nerd yeah
you own that yeah but if you're calling
me someone in a that's cool then is it
not something that you wear as a badge
is it is there still some insecurity
associated with me calling you a nerd
and saying oh you own that my assumption
was that it was a badge of honor at this
point yes there's very little insecurity
associated with the label now but the
thing that was once called nerd is a
thing that's still inside me and that
still is self-conscious so but as far as
quantifying that I think that there's
that the bit where you're quantifying
like okay to be clear like
people punched me for no reason because
like I was the person who looked like
the person you should punch you know and
then and then there's like the positive
ways to quantify your nerdiness like I
can tell you an awful lot about Star
Trek The Next Generation mm-hmm and all
and like weirdly I I have been
self-conscious about being able to
identify as a nerd because I'm afraid I
don't know certain nerdy things well
enough I don't know very much about
Dungeons and Dragons for example I never
played Dungeons & Dragons as a kid I've
only played it as an adult and so I kind
of feel weird about not having that D&D
street cred
who's the supreme who what's the
standard who's who where's the biggest
badge of honor
yeah being a nerd and do you wrestle
with being somewhere on that spectrum of
oh I'm less than nerd I don't want to be
more know I I don't know that I'm afraid
of not being nerdy enough but I must
sometimes afraid of being found in a
situation where I don't have street cred
in that particular bit of a nerd realm
cuz you feel like you should know you
gotta know those things was like I made
my friends play D&D with me a few years
ago because I was like I need to know
how this works got a lot of catching up
to do to be able to participate in these
conversations which is it's just the the
irony of nerdiness being characterized
in your youth in feeling kind of left
out like you're not part of something
yeah but then feeling the same way about
nerd culture now not crazy because it's
not really about nerd culture it's about
the human condition well you're always
gonna feel left out of something you're
always gonna like inadequate like
feeling inadequate is like if you don't
feel that you're probably a little
broken yeah it's it's gonna come up
every once in a while right there's
nothing worse than feeling left out of
the thing that you feel like you should
be in yeah I do like sometimes find
myself reading more young adult novels
than I would otherwise do in order to
like be into the nerdy things that my
audience is into mm-hmm but mostly I
read sci-fi novels because that's what I
like do you enjoy it and it's not I'm
not reading sci-fi novels to look like a
cooler nerd a more nerdy nerd I'm
reading them because like I freaking
love it what about below you on the
spectrum though there's people that you
see there aren't really nerds who are
like trying to get in on the nerd
right yeah how do you interact with that
I just sort of saved more power to it
the thing about being a nerd is it's
more than just a cultural identifiers
it's also like there are things about
being nerdy that are good for humans
like being enthusiastic and excited and
if you're enthusiastic and excited
that's good because I'm tired of people
being all cynical and ironic all the
time hmm that you know like nerdiness is
about knowing things about the world and
I think if more people don't know more
things more objectively true things
that's a good thing for everybody but I
do see sometimes I'm feeling a little
bit like maybe this person just wants to
like look the look and bandwagon atre
nerd poster don't really feel it but you
know Who am I to tell who that person is
or how they're feeling and like what
they you know what they actually
experience because a lot of that's just
gonna be based on what they look like
which is not true very little to do with
anything
well and for you what part nature what
part nurture is your nerd you parents
your parents nerdy my dad's my dads
can't see two inches in front of his
face without his glasses his glasses way
more than a small dog and so his neck is
huge it's got a great neck your dad is
one of the nicest people I've ever met
so nice yeah we just we we just met him
in passing at VidCon right uh yeah I
have great parents my mom is also
amazing she's a little bit less nerdy
but we did me and my mom watch x-files
together mm-hmm which is a pretty nerdy
show and she was super into that my dad
and I watched Doogie Howser MD together
Doogie Howser was an important role
model okay did you have a computerized
journal before anyone else had
computerized journals I did I did have a
computer Journal I think starting in
1995 maybe could you give me just a
paraphrase of something that you might
have written in a journal and is very
angsty it would probably have have read
something like people are so fake they
say hi to each other in the hall like it
matters
[Laughter]
Wow yeah no you he was a tough few is
that hypothetical or are you actually
accessing em Bo I'm remembering write it
like I write typing that I'm not
remembering writing it I'm rereading it
later remembering and reading it once I
got to college and like found those
files yeah man always curious if he
still had the files no I don't I don't I
lost a great deal of my terrible
terrible ramblings which there goes the
rationale of doing it that way at all
you should have printed it off on that
printer with the dots on the side for
the transfer the transfer of information
is different now you know back there was
this floppy disk right I mean it was on
a hard drive it was on a hard drive yet
still I think how you connect to
anything else right now it is you know
you're basically trusting Google not to
lose your email and they better not or
else we will be very angry yeah if they
don't lose your email then you can
probably say most of your data is safe
in Google's hands so do you remember the
first time that you were slapped with
the label of nerd and it hurt because
that's what I seem to have been
accessing earlier I remember when I hit
middle school that suddenly I wasn't
cool anymore and that they're like the
thing that I was it wasn't just that I I
wasn't coolest that the thing that I was
in elementary school which was cool
which was smart and knowing stuff and
doing well on tests was suddenly not
cool anymore and was this still in was
this in Montana no I grew up in Orlando
did you do the boarding school thing no
who stayed back yes dude in a couple of
videos when you talk about sexuality
sometimes on vlogbrothers okay I'm
talking about this and then you kind of
give more of this is what's behind this
for me personally mm-hmm so you would
talk about trying to reach a conclusion
about your own sexuality sexual
orientation and then you said that I
might be a little bi yeah but so was I
mean was everything up for grabs at that
point in it just a bunch of confusion I
remember it so so my sexual journey I'm
I'm pretty damn straight when it comes
down to it but I was for a little bit
terrified that I might be gay which I
knew was a bad thing which of course
isn't but I knew that it was because I
liked to ice skate and I liked the
Village People
and so I thought that that meant that I
might be gay so you don't like them
together having no I like to ice skate
to the village okay well then yeah you
were gay I was like remember like I
broke out in a cold sweat cuz I was like
yeah and I was like you realized it
maybe I'm gay and I was but this had
nothing to do with being attracted to a
man but I dude I did I the the men that
I have been attracted to I think it
requires two things one for me to be
pretty what's the good Randy and be like
well that guy but i'ms really it's like
well really anything and to it to be a
fairly effeminate yeah that guy looks
like a girl that guy looks like a cute
girl okay so I I think that like during
middle school I was just terrified that
I might be gay and during high school I
was just like well I'm outcast so I
might as well embrace the outcast miss
in whatever way is available to me so if
some guy wanted to make out I'd tried
that I went to a very large high school
and so there were a lot of social groups
there are a lot of different groups of
people you could be a part of that had
very different aesthetics and very
different values and so the group I was
ended up being a part of was very weird
and silly and non-traditional and and
really into that and this only happened
in senior of high school when I was able
to like embrace this stuff and the
silliness was really an important part
of it but so was not the like the
traditional way of looking at things we
want to see what parts of the world are
just made up and what parts are real so
that that was actually really great for
me what parts of the world were real and
what partially made it so so what what
did you discover was not real well I
mean I was 17 so yeah but you know you
start to realize that a certain point in
your life that the world doesn't have to
be the way that the world is and that's
sort of like at 16 year old seventeen
year old realization and I think it
happens earlier when you're more outside
of culture like we listen to Hanson
which was for high school students crazy
right like Hanson was for kids so it was
intentionally ridiculous
we're like Hanson that's weird like that
would be a weird thing
high school kids still Institue and then
like after the Hanson song you listen to
a Marilyn Manson song like like let's be
like intentionally ridiculous for sure
we named we renamed all the days of the
week we went and hung out at like you
know four in the morning and cemeteries
one night and the next night we'd be in
a playground at 4:00 in the morning and
one of the group had a very
non-supervisory dad it just sort of
always one stayed in his room and never
came out and we would just dance and
sing and stay up and play a
vacuum-cleaner fights and nobody ever
made out with anybody which i think was
like hugely important to the success of
this social group right I thought you
were getting at one time you made out
with one guy to see if you were gay we
never made out I was in I was ready to
go there but it didn't happen but you
said in that vlog which I found to be
interesting I can't remember the guy who
he was helping you added something and
Damon Oh Stefan yeah it seems like you
really put him on the spot about his
sexuality but then you're the one who
came out I said I'm a little bi and I
couldn't tell if you thought that was a
joke or if you were just being honest I
think I'm a little bi and that like
sometimes I think guys are kind of cute
I think we might probably all be a
little bi but like I think the idea of
there being three labels for what your
sexuality is is kind of ridiculous
insofar as like if you're gonna give me
one of those three labels I think it's
ridiculous to give me the label of like
a hundred percent one thing all the time
forever cultures full it's constantly
whispering rules in your ear about what
you should want about who you should
want about how you should live your life
and like how you should fill the holes
of need inside you and like strip it
down and maybe say like not just like
how do I fill those holes but like where
did they come from what are they what
like why do I want asking what why do I
want is far more useful in the end and
asking what do I want because there's a
lot of freedom there mmm when you
realize like this thing that's driving
me nuts
really and yeah Orlando is not my
favorite place no offense people who
live in Orlando but I'm glad to not live
there anymore what did you get out of
there
I moved to when I went to college and to
1998
I went to st. Petersburg and then and
2003 I moved to Montana
okay so st. Petersburg College and what
did you study there I studied
biochemistry and also liberal arts
because you had to I had an art minor
actually when I looking back on that I'm
very glad that I did science like that I
got a degree in science and I'm also
very glad that I went to liberal arts
school where I could learn a lot of
different weird things and like take a
class on economics and take a class on
religious studies and you know did you
find a group of people there kind of
like that formative group senior year in
high school where you were asking and
answering questions and determining who
you were and what you were gonna believe
about yourself and life and people yeah
I definitely found a very good group of
people at college really quick and our
experience was one of like silliness
like feeling this is like one of the
most important attributes to me
what's the silliest thing you remember
from the college years I mean this is
still before videos right yeah I mean
though we did make some videos in high
school which hopefully I'll never see
the light of day oh yeah I would I would
love to see them but I would not love
for the internet to see them yes
silliest thing we did in college oh we
did Rocky Horror a lot we went to see
Rocky Horror Picture Show so you would
get dressed up yeah and we actually the
characters did a Rocky Horror Show at
school I was in a cast I was Rocky
Katherine my wife was Janet so that's
where you met Katherine yeah yeah we
were we lived very near by each other
what was that first meeting the first
time I remember meeting Katherine like
actually like remember seeing her this
is terrible was at night and she was
wearing a t-shirt and no bra it may have
been a little chilly something I've
never told my wife that this is like my
four earliest from memory of her first
movie yeah and she was like out in the
hallway she had just come out of her her
room and I said like a few words - what
did you say like you sure no no I don't
know what we were talking nice shirt
remember her boobs okay fine that's what
I remember so now you're really you've
never told her this yeah
but you're telling us really admit it to
myself e we're gonna have to give you
some brownie points some way to make up
for that now okay so and then what you
started dating uh not not immediately no
we we had a weird earlier relationship
how some guys her roommate was excitedly
in a new relationship upon getting to
college and that made things a little
uncomfortable for Kathryn and so I
offered or she asked I think if she
could sleep in my room and she slept in
my room for weeks with nothing happening
and then one night something happened
did you have a roommate also yeah Derek
so then Derek had to leave no we were
more subtle than her so you guys and you
guys jacked up as friends and then
hooked up and then it's all history from
there well there have been many things
that have happened since then we broke
up like twice whose fault was that
well the she was going back home I was
going back home and it was like wow
that's just about your decision yeah and
then we came back and we we weren't
together for a while because it was
weird and then we were and then we broke
up for a little while while we lived in
Missoula which was really hard after we
moved to Missoula together what moved
you there and then tell us when the just
clue me in to win the video when the
vlog brothers sat 2.0 started happening
so was it after that yeah okay so yeah
so what moved you get you graduated and
moved together you guys were like a
couple we we graduated four I got a job
doing chemistry I didn't love it and
Katherine had a job too in Florida and
then she got accepted into the
University of Montana and their
environmental studies program and she
got a full free year there you know and
we had been living like doing sort of a
long-distance thing and she was gonna go
over there and I was like well either
this relationship is over which I don't
want it to be or I moved to Montana and
I was like well I don't like my job and
I don't really like for it and Montana
sounds weird so let's do that and that
was like it's such a like looking back
like crazy decision but I have always
been a little bit of whatever kind of
person like I'd like I'd like dislike
decisions don't seem that important to
me you know like
options available X okay go so it wasn't
as much a testimony to your relationship
as it was to it's just a viable option
loved her a lot okay
cuz those could have been your brownie
points right there Hank even like I
loved her madly deeply forever and I had
to be with her
it was a done deal I'm not a whimsical
guy but Montana I'm not a whimsical guy
I love silliness I love this moment and
so many people's story knowing who you
are and knowing what you do and how many
things you have done and how many things
you are doing right now to know that
there was a time in which you were
moving to Montana without an idea of
what you were gonna do yeah
was that mentality which now I feel like
you're the guy who has to be doing
something or else you'll go nuts right
well yeah was that emerging at that
point oh yeah I was already doing that I
was already like all the time coming up
with ideas and doing weird things when I
like during that period of time after
college when I lived in Florida working
at that lab I started a website called I
hate I 4.com I forced the road that runs
through Orlando and it's terrible and
everyone hates it so I was like let's
start a website we're gonna talk about
transportation policy it's I hate i-4
calm and I like stole road signs like
political campaign road signs and and I
spray-painted I hate I for calm on them
I had a stencil and then I put him out
like on the on ramps and exits a
marketing campaign yeah and then like
literally within the day the local news
was calling me
we had a sponsor and we made like 200
bucks and like the server bill got
really expensive but like to me it was
like yeah doing a thing and I and it was
a political yes it wasn't just a forum
for people to vent to be clear on the
website really it was mostly just people
yelling about different genders or races
or age groups that were worse drivers
yeah what you funds but you've you've
fostered a community and you found
yourself a spokesman for something I
mean this is certainly a template yeah
that carries on and this may not have
been the first example and it certainly
won't be the last
so how did you abandon that when you
moved to Montana
to Montana and I remember being like oh
my god I have to like leave I hit I
4.com behind I'm like and like I got I
had so many emails I haven't thought
about this in a decade but I remember
like getting to Missoula and thinking
I'm still gonna run I hate I for calm in
Missoula and then and then within like a
week realizing that it but like it's
always been important to me to have
something that I'm doing and keep my
brain occupied and so like that site was
good for doing that in the space between
figuring out what I was gonna do in
Missoula and so when you got to Missoula
hey what did you do to make money and be
what did you do that was the next I hate
I for calm at first I applied for jobs
which was a long process I also just
walked into a couple television stations
and I was like I have experience doing
TV stuff and camera stuff and graphic
stuff if you need that and one of them
put me on as a contract like occasional
camera operator which I did camera
operation is super fun and local markets
because you just get to go to weird
things and they're like you need to be
here at this time then you're like okay
and then you watch this weird thing
happen whatever thing it'll is worthy
that day it's a good way they like
didn't get to know a community because
you get to go out all the things that
you would never go to like all the
community events and then I started to
think probably I should go back to
school so the second semester we were
there I took a couple classes I took one
environmental writing course in one
microbiology course and I decided to go
the non science route and like really
like at that point I was thinking I
could set myself up to write about
science which is something I'd always
wanted to do I like have always been a
huge fan of science communicators like
Carl Sagan and the writing staff of Star
Trek The Next Generation and you know
Beakman's world and Bill Nye and that
sort of thing mr. wizard all really cool
things to me and I had a subscription to
Scientific American thanks to my dad
from the time I was like 12 so and I was
always like found that to be
unquestionably very cool and whatever
that cool word means so I really enjoyed
that class I took anything took the GREs
and I did well and then I got into the
program with no problem and I Slyke was
a year behind Kathryn in the same
program she was in but I focused on
writing while she focused on policy and
then in the graduate program I went in
for environmental writing I started eco
geek org which was my environmental
technology blog this seed for him the
cause of environmentalism was that
something that your dad fostered from a
young age yeah probably because my dad
was actually the Florida State Director
of the Nature Conservancy for a long
time when I was growing up and that was
obviously an important household topic
and in Florida is a beautiful and
wonderful place to attempt to protect
and a very difficult place to actually
protect because it is also a wonderful
place to build houses in theme parks and
theme parks and targets and you know but
for you starting eco geek this is a big
thing for you right well that kind of
came from going through the
environmental studies program at the
University of Montana which was a big
pile of like here are the worst things
that are happening in the world and we
have to activate ourself to fix them
mm-hmm and me feeling powerless and
terrible and like we can talk about this
all day long but like I'm into science
and a lot of this conversation is about
how bad the things that science has
brought us are and so I feel like we're
sort of fighting against maybe one of
the greatest tools that we have in this
fight like we're pushing against science
when science could easily be like the
most effective possible solution to the
problems we're facing and I as a person
who was into that it seemed very
uncomfortable and angering and annoying
which I still deal a little bit with and
the environmental movement so I found
myself going home and like googling you
know what's what's the future of paper
are we gonna use trees in 20 years
what's the future of energy what's the
future of cars what's the future of air
travel like and and feeling better about
the world like we can fix things we've
done it over and over again we reach our
carrying capacity
then we push through it we're finally
starting to see an end a potential end
to the growth in the human population
like not in the next year or anything
but it's probably gonna happen and at
that point we can find a balance
potentially if we continue to develop
technology but if we don't do that we
will actually be in trouble if we fight
against the only tool that we have to
make it all work but these are the type
of things that that you are moving from
just reading about and becoming
encouraged to then saying I'm gonna be a
part of writing about this and create a
forum in a solution I don't know if it's
technically a forum but you know what I
mean my professor at the time John
Webber has said you know we're gonna
like it the class was called starting a
magazine and it's like start it like you
want to find something that you're
obsessed with and that you really into
because you're gonna be thinking about
this 24 hours a day and I was like well
what's that thing for me and then I like
looked at my google search history and I
was like this environmental technology
technology that will make our impact on
the environment less significant so
that's what that's what I started my
blog about and it became a thing that
was like my job for a while and at that
point I guess you were experimenting
with web video and so there was a
natural no evolution into YouTube like
how did that start there was no natural
evolution I was getting bored with the
Eco geek I was getting bored with
writing sensationalist headlines to try
and get clicks to try and get out
impression it to try and get money and I
didn't want to do that anymore but I
also saw like if I don't do that anymore
will I be able to pay the bills so I was
feeling like probably I was gonna have
to have another thing and John my
brother was like what do you think about
the idea of maybe doing a YouTube show
like videos and editing videos and we'd
talk to each other on the camera and and
we and I was like yes a thing a new
thing yes absolutely we should get bad
dad to buy us cameras for Christmas and
these are the ones we should get and
make sure we both have iMovie on our
Macs and I've tested it out and so dad
gave you both a camera for Christmas
Canon Elora 100s so then January 1st
your video goes up first yeah
and of course we talked to John his
video went up the day after but he put
it up on the wrong channel so it's a
little confusing we're not quite sure
how YouTube works at this point yeah but
so in your first video I found it
interesting that it's kind of presented
as if it's your idea I don't think that
was intentional no I did not mean to
imply that but but you were very gung-ho
I mean when John posts his first
Brotherhood 2.0 it's like I don't know
what I'm doing or this is gonna be very
bad at this yeah yeah but you seem to be
much more gung-ho and I'm sort of a more
excitable guy than John I get really
into new ideas like really and a new
idea and you were kind of fostering it
were kind of prompts at the beginning
like okay we got to get this thing off
the ground you're kind of giving him
some tracks to run on helping your
brother out well you should probably
post it on the right channel and we
let's talk about our differences here's
something we can go with kind of a thing
yeah I mean he did that too I mean and
we it was clear to me watching those
videos that we wanted other people to
watch them it's not like we just were
making a youtube show where we were
gonna talk to each other John was like
you know what we should do we should eat
toilet paper while talking about the
political situation in Nepal right and
it's like as a punishment no that was
alright that wasn't a partisan idea I'm
decided that that would be a good idea
right like you know we can talk about
how we didn't really think that it was
gonna be popular we didn't really think
it was gonna be popular of course we
didn't like YouTube as it exists now is
unthinkable to 2007 YouTube but but you
were thinking overlaying an audience
larger than yourselves how do we get
people to watch this and did you assume
a character I think as soon as the
camera turns on and you're not a
professional performer you're a
character like you immediately start
acting different when there's a camera
on so yeah there's a character there in
that like you're being self-conscious
and you're thinking about your thoughts
more and you're thinking about your face
and your presentation and where you're
talking more and then you're nervous and
like so there's difference but if you
watch the early videos it's a very
different character than the one I have
now which is more similar to me actually
because that guy was like putting on a
thing because obviously me as I am
not interesting enough so let's try
something else he was funny and you're
still funny but I mean it's you know
it's I mean we said I mean we we're very
different than the videos we made and a
lot of those like you said are not
anywhere for anyone to see what you know
and it's interesting how so many things
have sort of synthesized it with your
interests and your passions and your
knowledge with this medium and it seems
like one of the things that
characterizes so many of the things that
you do you really want people to know
things not in a preachy kind of way or
like I'm gonna teach you guys or I'm
gonna take you to school but I think
about it in the context of you know with
what we do it isn't that you don't ever
learn something from a good mythical
morning or whatever there is a
fascination factor but our primary
objective is to entertain and I think
people kind of get that yours is equally
entertaining but I feel like you have a
passion for people to get things for
things to sink in yeah to enjoy the
ever-present game of knowing oh yeah
that's a good Hank Hank green quote yeah
I am super into that because I love it
when people do that to me I love it when
someone explains something to me in a
way where I finally get it this is now a
thing that I will always have in my head
a greater understanding of how the
universe works knowing what is actually
true about something is empowering it
seems like everything that you touch on
you're trying to give people knowledge
that they can be equipped to then do
what I think understanding the world is
its own reward in a lot of ways in the
past we got to have that provided for us
like a certainty which i think is just
really inaccessible now you know
religion provides for a lot of people
and I'm often envious of this that kind
of certainty that kind of like I
understand not just what the world is
but my place in it and what I should do
and how I should operate and when you
break that down when you when you don't
have that you can feel like you're lost
and like you're just sort of tumbling
and when it comes to like why you're
here we don't have a great answer for
that there
really like in my opinion isn't one like
there's no cosmic purpose to any
individual human life but if you
understand your connection to other
people and if you understand yourself
not just sort of like how I think and
how I feel the like why I think and why
I feel and that for me has really
allowed me to like understand that like
I have a reason in any given moment if I
feel lost I can touch on that reason and
feel like that's still that's still
there and like that's a weird thing to
come to from a place of like I want
people to understand all of the universe
and and I want to be able understand
like why shoes fall when you drop them
and I want people to understand like
what wood is made out of - like I also
want people to understand that they have
a thing called humanity that has not
just cultural needs but like real
objective intrinsic needs this quest for
knowledge do you think that there is a
point in which we attain the knowledge
from an objective standpoint that then
answer some of those questions as you so
you don't feel upside down or out of
place where you find purpose in the
endless knowledge yeah no I mean I think
I don't think that like necessarily
science does that but I think that under
psych that observation can lead an
individual human to find that for
themselves and I think that that's
happened for me to find her path maybe
not purpose but to find the thing that
that shows you which way is up that like
you can always touch on to say here is
the thing that makes sense for why I'm
here and like I guess purposes is an
acceptable word and this is an
interesting difference between you and
John yeah yeah you know he's been really
totally open about his background we
talked with him and the interesting
thing is that you guys are so in
lockstep about so many things and when
we asked him this question about how
does this you know he considers himself
to have faith in God and you don't
mm-hmm but yet so you call yourself an
atheist right the see this is important
so I don't believe there's a god but I'm
not comfortable saying that there is no
God because I've had people ask me is
there a God and I'm like well like I
can't like Wow so that's a very
different question then I don't then do
you believe there's a god
but where were you going with your
question yeah with with Jeff we asked
him how you guys interact about that his
answer was well we don't really
specifically about that issue because we
care about the same things you you guys
are oriented in the same way you want to
decrease worldsuck in the same way and
the motivation seems to come from maybe
different areas but you when you all is
said and done you're doing the same
thing yeah and I think that we like we
have the same values it I mean it's like
not important where the values come from
it's important what the values are so do
you have a sort of a pact
that's like we're not going to discuss
that or is it all the time you do okay
and and what what was the tone of that
conversation like usually it's it's more
like curiosity mm-hmm and like you know
like maybe a little bit of like what is
that giving you like I find myself often
those being jealous of religion like
it's a it's an amazing community
organizer it's the reason why
Republicans give more to charity than
Democrats and I'm like we'd like
obviously secular people need something
to make them give money because like
that's frustrating to me like that like
right I think people would maybe ask you
why do you want to decrease worldsuck if
you're not doing it for God well I mean
what I find that question very funny so
who are you doing it for the people who
suffer I mean I think that's a terrible
thing to think like like the only reason
I want to help people is so I don't burn
forever what a terrible way to look at
the world well let's let's talk a little
bit more about about your brother
because it has been obviously an
incredible year yeah for him we talked a
lot about that on his appear biscuit and
we want to get your perspective on some
of those same questions because even in
that I guess it was your second video
post you were talking about how people
compared you to him that's true you know
ed that was yeah I'm always impressed by
how much research you guys do well that
was that was the first thing you chose
to talk to him and the audience that you
were just
let's talk about how we're different
because people always talk to me about
what I'm not that you are or vice versa
you know what did I say he said that he
was pudgy and that you you would you had
become pudgy over the next few years
that's a good joke you said that it was
a good comedy bed it really was and then
you turn it into a bit about basically
it was your confession of spilling
coffee on Katherine's computer here he
would he would never do that or a beer
yeah and then not telling her and then
waiting to the next morning and just
replacing the battery and didn't hoping
that it works because he didn't want to
have to tell her what happened John
would never do that
yeah insinuating that you did do that
[Laughter]
what happens when your brother has this
monstrously successful novel which turns
into a monstrously successful movie and
you're saying I'm not monstrously
successful is that what you're implying
he's saying what does it feel like to be
the inadequate brother saying when you
haven't done those things specifically
it impacts me not at all like I don't
see like that doesn't feel like a thing
in my life that tension doesn't feel
like a thing in my life
John's success is like a thing to deal
with that we have to think about and
that changes maybe some of the ways that
he thinks about our projects there are
often times when John's like why would
we do that and I was like because of
money and he's like I forgot about money
[Laughter]
I'm not there
forgot about money so there are ways
that has changed John and like and so I
have like I have to think about that and
that and I wouldn't say any of it is
negative I don't think that it's changed
John in any negative ways except that
he's possibly maybe a little more
anxious but as far as the tension of
success goes I have people ask me about
that a lot and my parents have it as
well like they're like how how does how
does Hank feel about not being you know
being in his brother's shadow and like
on vlogbrothers I'm not at all I don't
feel at all in my brother's shadow
I don't think nerdfighteria thinks about
it that way at all I don't think people
come into it and they're like well I
like John's videos but Hanks just yeah
you just have to wade through those
frankly my videos are more entertaining
and I'm better at making video than he
is and he will agree he's a better
writer than I am but also at the same
time he's focusing more and like I can
tell he's doing this intentionally on
the boring stuff and he's letting me do
more exciting videos to make sure that
people like they'll watch John's videos
cuz he's John but then they get to be
like oh thank goodness I hain't video I
get to not have to think about Ethiopia
for a nap like you say you can tell like
when you post a video there's no
coordination in terms of I'm tackling
this so don't you can leave this one
there's a little coordination some time
I mean on the average day I have no idea
what John's video is gonna be about and
you watch it along with everyone else
yeah I sigh so for example the one that
went up today the day were recording
this I did know what it was gonna be
about but that's because he wanted me to
look over the script because it had
science in it are there days when for
both of you it would be a surprise but
you just don't get around to watching
your brothers video there might be a day
where that happened you'll catch up in
fact today is a day when that happened I
haven't watched that video yet one I've
read the script so I know it's about but
I will watch it it's just that I've been
driving around La all day if ever I get
to the point where I don't watch one of
John's videos that's the day I just we
might as well not have the channel
anymore
yeah like because like that's the thing
he like he's making a video for me
mm-hmm
and if I'm not watching it one that's
just bad brother right there and to like
it's like it abandons the idea of what
it is and the idea of what it is remains
very important that we are making videos
for each other even though of course we
recognize and communicate with the
broader audience like I will say
something that John already knows and I
won't say it to John and I'll say it to
the audience
but John remains the most important
member of the audience and I think that
that's like that's the way it has
to be for Vlach where this to be what it
is when you guys decided that you were
going to when you realized that the
success was happening
stars who instigated the conversation to
be like alright we should probably talk
about this and how we're gonna manage
this I don't know it was definitely a
conversation we had but I think that it
was I think it might have just come up
early when we were like this is turning
into a movie and the movie might be very
successful and like that sort of came up
in conversation and if it is then what's
like that the way John and I don't have
agenda so when we call each other on the
phone like right like right down bullet
points or anything occasionally but not
agree yeah I mean we knew that there was
a chance that this would be something
that we would have to manage and it
turned out to be something that we did
have to think actively about mm-hm and
it was definitely a conversation that
involved both of us and concluded with
we do not want to capture the wave this
is not a wave we want to ride to not see
it as okay this is the opportunity to
take vlogbrothers to a whole new level
this is not as what we got to do I think
it was too big if we caught that wave it
would change our community it would have
changed our community what would you
have had to do to catch the wave yeah we
would have had immediately obvious to me
what she would change oh yeah I mean
like we were encouraged on several
fronts to have The Fault in Our Stars
sort of become the narrative of the vlog
where there's channel for a long time
before and after the movie came out just
- you guys are just talking about the
whole maybe experience also I think sort
of more demographically aimed and making
that kind of content and collaborating
with those like people who who have that
demographic watching their shows and I
think if we hadn't used that strategy
have you know a tremendous amount of
subscriber growth and we didn't do that
very intentionally because we didn't
want we didn't want to have our audience
double but have our audience double with
entirely an entirely new kind of viewer
right that would have been terrifying we
wouldn't know what our channel was
anymore because like the people who are
watching
content are just as important as the
people who are making the content in
terms of what kind of content ends up
getting made so we want to keep making
the same kind of content we've always
made so we not only did we avoid
creating content specifically for Pete
for fans of the movies who might be
coming in for the first time as lab
reviewers we sort of double down on what
nerdfighteria was and on what our kind
of content was I mean there's a number
of things that you've invested in that
are equally is phenomenal as the success
of the novel or the book and those
things are maybe not equally as
phenomenal well there's there's a
phenomenon in mass cultural success of a
story that is very difficult to
duplicate in any other way and that like
that cultural importance is so awesome
I'm very proud of John and like that's
an accomplishment that very few people
get to have and I think that he doesn't
either he doesn't recognize it or he
doesn't want to because of how important
it is for a lot of people and as how
like important it will be for their
whole lives
like John has a number of authors that
have impacted him tremendously and he is
going to be that for a lot of people and
I think that that's true of vlog
brothers as well but it is not like not
in the same way as The Fault in Our
Stars mm-hmm at the same magnitude but I
mean when you look at things like how
much money has been raised through
project for awesome or the benefits of
an event like VidCon yeah they're so
instrumental to shaping a whole genre of
entertainment mm-hm and so I guess I
make the point that these other things
that you've created or yeah and I'm
extremely of the things that that like
I've done personally I'm like and also
like it's not really about pride it's
about doing something that I think is
important and interesting and like that
is hard you do so many things I mean
what what's the thing that if you had to
have only done one of them what was the
thing you couldn't let go of so marriage
okay there you go you got a top of mind
that was good got it back professionally
not personally log brothers
vlog brothers log brothers vlog with
every department all of the other things
don't like wouldn't have been possible
and and wouldn't matter without
nerdfighteria I mean like that channel
is the coolest thing that ever happened
to me
do you guys agree that the thing that
you do for a living is so cool yeah yeah
yeah it's living a dream it is it really
is it's great so I'm just I'm infinitely
grateful to all the people who care
about that channel and also who care
about the institution as a community and
care about us as individual creators and
care about each other as as members of
that thing so cool so cool fixed because
of VidCon know what you've done is that
you've you've aligned everyone who's
trying to do anything that makes them a
youtuber which is such a broad term yeah
you're like the friendly uncle of every
youtuber and I'm glad you think so
because of VidCon
do you watch everyone's content because
it seems to me that you really know and
care about youtubers like Oh
Jenna's getting flak on Good Morning
America who's gonna write a blog post
about it to set him and put him in their
place
Hank Green's gonna do that friendly
VidCon uncle how do you see your role in
that capacity I would love to be
friendly uncle I if in like I am really
into online video I think a lot of
people came into this with the sort of
like aspirations that involved
entertainment I had none of those I'm
had a little bit of a maybe I wanted to
do science communication but that world
continues to be boring to me and at that
point it was just opaque or like I
hadn't even considered it existed and so
like being a part of the early days of
YouTube is like that's like I think one
of the coolest things that that will be
a part of my life and I thought from
like day two that YouTube was going to
be it not was gonna be was already a
huge deal like a huge culturally
important deal because I mean I was
always obsessed with the culture of the
internet and YouTube was a big part
like early u2 was a big part of the
culture of the internet so I I've always
been obsessed with it and I've always
thought that it mattered and it seems
like only recently even the people who
are involved in it even the people who
do it for a living
only recently have they come a lot of
them come to accept that it is important
whereas from like like 2010 when I
started VidCon I thought it was late for
a conference 2007 when I started making
YouTube videos I thought I was late to
YouTube like I'm looking at the the the
dimming of the table here and I'm like I
see all these names and I like to me
what this looks like
isn't is not a table with a bunch of
signatures on it it's like a thing
that's gonna be in a museum someday I
believe completely irrationally in the
deep importance of online video
culturally hmm like I think it's as
important as like the printing press
which I know it's not but I think it is
and it's interesting that you but you
find yourself being the champion of
people who youtubers who are just in it
to scratch their entertainment niche I
mean that's not what that's what we
really like that's not what it's about
it's not about like am I just getting it
using this as a stepping stone it's
about they're making great content I
don't care if they're using this
stepping stone I care if they're making
great content I care if they're doing
something interesting something
different something cool what trends do
you see in all our video that trouble
you um the thing that makes me the most
angry in all the world is watching
people who suck get really rich off of
people who are cool like yeah and then
the other thing that really pisses me
off is that people are too nice to call
them out on it
which I am doing right now right we
can't say anything bad about anybody
this yeah industry yeah it doesn't work
doesn't go over well it would work if we
all did it I asked that question all the
time like when I'm when I'm so it's like
sort of getting into a new area of
YouTube likes a Minecraft gamers or you
know acapella musicians I'm like so just
to like just tell me who's the like
who's the because you know that there is
one right and I know that you all hate
them but you're not going to tell me and
he's first of all you're assuming you're
not talking to him that's true but I'd
I'd pick carefully okay yeah the person
I asked that question too and what are
they no one ever says no say privately
no they won't
they're too nice and they know and they
and they don't just know that that
person is you know only motivated by
money they know that that person has
done bad things to people and I feel the
same way I know people who have done bad
things to people and I don't talk about
it because it's not something you're
supposed to talk about and I find it
very frustrating it's and it's a thing
like that like the snow that I feel like
this is a problem that we have to work
around but boy does it make me want to
not have that problem anymore
I'd so want that problem to go away but
yes I'm a little surprised that that's
what you said I mean I really thought
your answer was gonna be related to well
you know the established entertainment
industry is gonna come in you ask me a
really great question I answered with
the thing I hate the most in the world I
probably shouldn't have done but I maybe
just really wanted to have that rant I
just had but let's go with at random
because I mean you tweeted I suppose I
feel somewhat alienated from the idea of
what a quote youtuber is that's it makes
me wonder if that's something I want to
be that was a moment of weakness I
shouldn't have tweeted that but you did
tweet it so explain it and that and that
that is that the the word youtuber means
different things to different people but
I had at that moment heard the word
youtuber used probably 12 times in a row
in describing teen idols and I have
nothing against teen idols I'm not
saying to make bad content
I'm not saying that they like but the
enthusiasm of twelve-year-old girls is
like a problem like but that's what a
youtuber is is a like I kept hearing it
used in that way good-looking guy
vlogger that girls swoon over yeah
equals youtuber period yeah and like and
I think that is what that word means to
a lot of people and I worry that that's
gonna be what that word means to the
mainstream like that would not be fun
for me because then we need a new word
you guys but I think I think that I'm
still like absolutely hundred percent
youtuber the other thing is that people
who work for YouTube YouTube employees
call themselves youtubers and I'm like I
know you guys know that's ours
I am very proud to be a youtuber and I
think I'm a youtuber anything always be
a youtuber maybe the word creator is
sort of like let like it's certainly
more vague but but maybe more
appropriate for use in certain
situations but I think that online video
is a thing that will always be a thing
like radio is a thing that will always
be a thing like plays are a thing that
will always be a thing I think it's a
it's a new form of media
it isn't just it's not a genre it's as
different from TV as TV is different
from radio and it's weird to have a word
for that thing that's the name of a
website but I'm perfectly happy with it
like to me when I say youtuber what I
think of is people who make content on
YouTube and people watch it and and like
that's anybody it people who don't know
you watch it
that's what a youtuber is and you're
concerned about them making content is
actually good
I thought your concern was gonna be that
the power will be taken from the
individual and would just wind up in the
hands of the gatekeepers of traditional
entertainment we were gonna go down that
path I guess I am but only insofar as it
is something that's going to happen and
I'm not going to enjoy it if you're not
gonna give us hope that the YouTube is
gonna friendly uncle Hank it's not give
us hope I mean when I was in the panel
let me say when I was on the panel at
VidCon called the future of online
entertainment yeah what's been a weird
thing happened to me sitting in the seat
you wet yourself on the pants I peed
myself
at one point I thought my eyes might be
welling up yeah and I'm being serious
I'm not joking I felt like wow we have
enough success as youtubers to maybe be
able to help affect what the future of
this is right and you kind of think yeah
we're helping invent this and we're
racking our brains constantly to yes to
be successful yes to be entertaining and
we did know this but it kind of hit me
harder for some reason at that moment
that we have power to help shape the
opportunity that other people have to
follow in our footsteps
to live their dreams yeah so I'm hoping
that you
would give us some positivity right
uncle Hank associated with keeping the
you in YouTube writing the man comes in
to take the power they can't take all of
it like that like the cool thing about
YouTube is that there is no barrier to
entry I mean there is you have to have a
camera and an internet connection and
ideally a way to edit a video and as
long as that's the case people will be
doing things that mainstream media will
not get but will be very popular and
that is going to cause media to evolve
far more quickly than it has in the past
genres are created now as fast as
television shows used to be created and
it's a beautiful thing and so that is
that threatened it's not what I mean
when I say that that this is a foregone
conclusion is that in the future there
will be YouTube channels and there will
be youtubers who are basically run by
Hollywood and though it's gonna be less
magical than it is now and it already is
less magical now than it was a few years
ago and I have always wanted to and a
will always use the power of VidCon to
encourage what I see as legitimate
online video but at the same time I
think that it's important to like
recognize the path of power and the path
of and like people will follow money
people will do things for money and
money will be easier to come by when
you're talking to a Hollywood studio
that is used to throwing down ten
million dollars on something there's a
funny thing that people in Hollywood
will will say this this phrase that I
hear frustratingly frequently real money
and real money is implying that the
money that you and I used to buy our
cars and houses and and gasoline is not
real real money is when like you can no
longer breathe because of all the
hundred-dollar bills that they've
stuffed around you well let's let's
shift it in on a positive note what are
you most excited about I think online
video is gonna continue being like super
huge and super big and super diverse and
lots of interesting new things will keep
on happening and I think that the
mainstream will always be a step behind
and I think that is the cool part and I
think that like right now what you're
doing with good mythical
that to me seems like the mainstream is
a year or two behind this and this kind
of format is gonna be popular like it's
gonna be a genre I think right now you
guys are making a genre of video that
has never been created before and I
think that that's amazing but I don't
think it's at all unique it might not
even be exceptional
there's so many things happening and
it's easy to forget that like five years
ago there wasn't anybody doing this who
had an employee right and and now
finally we're starting to get to the
point where you know like there was this
weird moment where YouTube was like dump
money on people and see what you do and
and it didn't work because they went
from we went from like having just me
doing the writing and directing and
editing and talent and and you know
graphics and everything right it turns
out dumping money on people actually
hurts
yeah it's physically painful especially
if you use coins which I don't know why
they did that so instead of going from
just like one person doing all those
things he went to having ten people and
and one person did each one of those
things which was a bad decision what we
should have done is had two people
instead which I think is one of the
reasons why so many popular YouTube
channels are two person teams who
started out as either brothers or
whatever the heck you guys are friends
not quite little more than that but that
sounds weird old married couple desk
friends yeah and and and and so it's
only very it's only very recently that
we diversified we like moved on from
having just one person doing everything
to two people doing everything yeah and
then three people doing everything and
it's you can do so many more interesting
things but you have to let it evolve
naturally you have to let that that
progression occur in order to see how
that changes what can be done because
what can be done with three people is
very different from what can be done
with one person and the kind of content
you end up making is very different but
that doesn't mean that the one person
vlog is gonna go away because that's a
legitimately in
trysting format it's legitimately
interesting genre it's like stand-up
comedy right it's it's it's like a mix
of like essay and video and stand-up and
you get to do all kinds of different
things you can play multiple parts like
Natalie or superwoman or you can be
talking about you know like the
complexities of the marriage equality
debate in America you're exactly right
the just the rapidity of genres being
created is it's amazing and it's
fascinating and you're right that
there's this wave of content that is
being created in this digital realm that
is the future of so many different
things and it's fun to be riding that
wave and I know that when we look
forward and we see what those next
things are that you're gonna be there
you know what we're just committed to
being able to look around and be in that
space and be able to see people like you
so do you guys know you're you know you
guys know you're ahead of the curve you
got it you gotta know you're ahead of
the curve you do such cool innovative
interesting things I'm proud to be in
your studio right now and this has been
a great ear biscuit all you got to do is
sign this table man so I went yes
whenever it's whenever we get it put in
that museum you're talking about well
for the person who's listening it out in
the year 4028 always said who's looking
and feeling a little bit slash in the
Smithsonian yeah yeah listening to it
while looking at the table yeah it's in
it's in an exhibit you press a button
well you're fine don't press the button
you probably think and it starts
I think Hank can say that our table is
in some museum but I don't think we
should just sign it let's try to end
self deprecating okay all right I'm
gonna start a museum and the first thing
I'm gonna put it in is this table yeah
if you guys ever move out of the studio
this is it all right is the museum is
here okay okay
undisclosed location thanks Hank oh
you're adding that yourself you don't
have to do that
[Music]
and there you have it our conversation
with Hank green feel like I could talk
to that guy forever there's so much that
he's done that we didn't even touch on
you could you get we could do a series
with Hank green well in just his
perspective you know on the state of
online video the future of online video
got lots of respect for what he's done
for the good of not only online video
but for humanity
I mean it's just cool to be in a space
and like we said living our dream and
part of that is getting to rub shoulders
and to become friends with people like
Hank who are not taking lightly the
responsibility that that we find
ourselves in in shaping this this whole
form of entertainment
yeah and I've always had a tremendous
amount of respect for Hank and you know
it only increased and talking to him I
think to pinpoint one thing that was
just so impressed me was of his
perspective on the way that they thought
about Jon's success as a wave that they
didn't want to ride and to understand
the value of what they have created and
what they were cultivating as the vlog
brothers as nerdfighteria he just got so
much insight into that I don't know it's
there's almost a recenter in when you do
what you do what we do for a living you
talk to a guy like Hank there's this
Ries entering that that happens and you
kind of remember that like just it's
inspiring you know the to see it in such
a pure way what we're doing here in an
online video
yeah thanks Hank and you should pass
along what you think to Hank his Twitter
account is Hank green it's pretty
intuitive that's Hank it's like if you
if you were to make this sound honk but
with an A nothing - oh that's Hank green
on trick
tweet hashtag your biscuits Hank show
him your appreciation show me your love
and
that way well you know we'll also show
us your internet love that could be an
iTunes review or just just general
gushing about your biscuits to people
whose opinion you respect Rangers even
yes yo strangers about the people on
public transportation that you know like
you that you're awkward right now if you
are in a public place
tell them I'm listening to ear biscuits
just say it just scream it out check it
out like add that see you I'm doing it
right now
hopefully you just did that and thank
you for that we really appreciate it
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]